hey welcome back to New Rockstars it's
me Mt and that new Spider-Man 2 gameplay
was insane right about damn time we were
able to swing around the city of New
York covered in hungry Murder Inc it is
a crime that we haven't been able to
play in the symbiote suit since
Spider-Man Web of Shadows all the way
back in 2008 and I for one was getting
tired of not seeing my spidered men go
through an email phase some would say
that I've been craving it
I love a good pun but anyways let's get
into the breakdown of this absolutely
crazy Gameplay trailer because did you
see Peter turn that man's ribs and lower
regions into a fine powder we've got to
talk about it but like always do not
forget to hit up nerd riot.shop today so
that you can buy a really cool nerd
shirt or any other piece of nerd
merchandise for you or somebody that you
love nerdwide.shop is the number one
place for nerd stuff check it out today
you grow slow in your old age
yeah
a fate you will not share
all right guys so let's talk about
craving the hunter this dude is beastly
in this trailer like did you notice the
way that he freaking effortlessly picked
up that dude with one arm and then broke
his arm with his other arm before
killing him like Insomniac games did an
incredible job capturing the sheer
strength of craving the hunter from the
comics because Sergey cravenov is very
much a super soldier much like both the
Spider-Man are in the comics Craven gets
the enhanced strength speed and
endurance that makes him a match for
Spider-Man from some magic Voodoo Juice
that he stole from an African tribe but
speaking of Craven's victim he very much
appears to be dressed like someone
within Craven's clan of hunters the main
antagonistic Army that Peter and Miles
face in this trailer but his Russian
sounding accent and the way that he says
that Craven has gotten slow in his old
age hint at a degree of close
familiarity that this particular Hunter
could have had with Craven like he might
have even been family like the way
Craven closes his eyes after he kills
this Hunter implies to me that Craven
felt a little bit of genuine sadness to
see this and die but unfortunately
weakness cannot be tolerated amongst the
most elite Hunters on the planet
possibly a reference to The Amazing
Spider-Man 637 when Craven snapped his
own wife's neck before forcing his kids
to hunt one another to toughen up the
family that Craven is straight up a
Savage man and I can totally see Craven
and the Venom symbiote merging by the
end of this story as they are both
ruthless Predators I mean Craven does
pretend to be Symbiote Spider-Man for a
time after he buries Peter alive in the
comics so Craven's super soldier blood
and murderous disposition would probably
be super enticing to a Venom Symbian and
this all of course leads Craven the
hunter to search for new prey to kill
and beautiful crime infested New York
City a city filled with exceptional
heroes and villains of all kinds in
Craven's map of potential targets
include characters established in both
Spider-Man 1 and Spider-Man Miles
Morales including Felicia Hardy black
cat Aaron Davis Prowler Yuri watanabe's
Rave after she turned to the dark side
of crime fighting in these Silver Lining
DLC Tombstone Peter Parker and Miles
Morales Spider-Man of course and then we
also have four members of the Sinister
Six team consisting of vulture Rhino Doc
Ock and Electro with Martin Lee and
scorpions suspiciously missing here
followed by Kingpin shocker Taskmaster
and Kurt Connors the lizard who serves
as the focal point for the rest of this
gameplay footage as Craven's Hunters
invade New York six months later
specifically Queens one of the new areas
that we'll be able to explore in this
game along with East River where we get
our cool lizard Chase and actually this
scene happens in the wee hours of the
morning in fact as the computer in one
of the hunter Vehicles notes that they
all got their ribs kicked in by an emo
nerd around 8 36 a.m possibly trying to
get a jump on the lizard while he was
still asleep or you know reading the
morning lizard paper but that would be
potentially catastrophic for Harry
Osborne survival because if you remember
Dr Connors is first introduced in the
post credits for the Miles Morales game
as a scientist employed by Osborne to to
unlock the healing properties of the
Venom symbiote and since Kurt Connors
knows Harry's Health the best and is the
one who releases the Symbiote from that
science tube on Osborne's orders
catching the lizard is absolutely
crucial to Harry's survival and great
news guys this video is sponsored by
Helix sleep their Memorial Day sale is
running now and it is a great time to
upgrade your mattress because you can
get 25 off your purchase for a limited
time no matter what kind of sleeper you
are Helix has a mattress for you their
sleep quiz makes it easy to find the
perfect match I wanted a medium firm
mattress with lumbar support that sleeps
cool so I got matched with the dusk Lux
Helix mattress I've had my Helix
mattress for well over a year now and I
freaking love this thing I fall asleep
faster sleep deeper and find it easier
to share a bed with a special lady you
know what I'm saying in my dreams Helix
delivers right to your door with free
shipping in the US and the package is
like some type of magic box I don't know
how they fit an entire mattress in this
box but they summoned the wizard to do
ain't no way this is about to be a whole
mattress right now ain't no way look at
this it's all curled up like the
mattress comes rolled up in a box and
it's super easy to set up yourself and
if you're nervous to buy something that
you haven't test driven Helix has a 100
night sleep trial so that you'll have
more than three months to make sure that
you love it Helix mattresses also have a
10-year warranty and they offer
financing options and flexible payment
plans so a great night's sleep is never
far away I love my Helix mattress and I
think you will love yours too their
Memorial Day sale is running now and
it's the perfect time to upgrade your
sleep with 25 off a helix mattress plus
two free pillows just click the link in
the description below or go to
helixleaf.com rockstars to find out more
about this limited time offer we think
Helix sleep again for sponsoring this
video you guys are amazing and have
helped me sleep so well for so long you
guys are the goats but it looks like the
lizard may have Justice ape prior to the
Hunter's arrival by busting through that
Cellar Door that black suit Spider-Man
Actually emerges from in the trailer
implying that Connors may have run away
from Peter after Peter confronted him at
Kurt Connor's home but anyways let us
finally set our sights on spidey's sick
Sleek symbiote suit like this man is
wilding out in style I especially love
how the suit remains Comics accurate by
having the spider logo in the front wrap
all the way around to the back spider
logo while also reaping new life into
the design by making the Symbiote feel
like the living organism that it is by
giving the suit muscle tendons on the
neck arms and legs but the real star of
the show here is of course the absolute
brutality that this black suit
Spider-Man is going to be dealing out in
this game which also gives Peter Parker
a whole new set of dark abilities
accessible by pressing L1 as seen on the
bottom left of the screen he opens the
fight by using one of the Venom
abilities to smash that Hunter into that
jeep with a huge Venom arm of tendrils
before using another one of those Venom
abilities to cover himself in a symbiote
bubble and Barrel through the remaining
group and the crazy Savage finishers
that Peter Parker deals out with the
Venom Suit are out of this world and
truly show just how much the Symbiote
has already begun to feed feed on Peter
Parker's anger at Craven and his fear of
losing Harry to the same terminal
illness that took Harry's mom like
combat is going to be nuts in this game
especially now that Insomniac has added
a period mechanic to the series like
some attacks executed by enemies will
have to be buried by Spider-Man in order
for him to find an opening to give them
internal bleeding like he does here my
God he absolutely killed that man tap
danced on his ribs and everything and to
wrap up the sequence Peter uses a third
of his L1 Venom abilities that allows
him to tendril grab multiple enemies
from a distance and then slam them to
the ground for an instant KO like my God
is the Spider-Man in need of a Snickers
one of the details in this trailer that
might be easy to miss is the design of
the bullet warning indicators for Peter
Parker which looked completely different
than they were for Peter Parker in the
past as they are designed here to look
more like Audio Waves I thought that
though it's an incredibly clever way to
show that the Symbiote has connected
itself with Peter Parker's spider-sense
as all symbiotes are famously afraid of
fire and sound two things that guns
produce in excess like giving black suit
Spider-Man audio wave warnings was super
dope and shows that insomnia games truly
does their homework and cares about
getting the Venom to build right for
this game but the best parts of this
trailer are when we see Peter Parker
being the darker more selfish version of
himself that made his original black
suit story in the comics so iconic like
Peter truly does not give a single damn
about any single human if he feels like
they're getting in the way of what he
wants in his mission even his own spider
partner Miles Morales who he only calls
when he's annoyed that he can't complete
his mission by himself miles the hunters
track Connors to the Harlem fish market
[Music]
sounds like Craven's shutting off his we
don't have much time move
uh guess we'll chat later like I love
how he absolutely shuts miles down with
this small talk because the Symbiote has
given his rage a laser-like focus like
he straightened up doesn't say hello to
miles at any point during this footage
and he basically only says things to
miles that gets him to do the things
that Peter wants while also straight up
completely ignoring genki's existence as
Genki Pilots a hijacked Hunter bird
foreign
ER Mr Spider-Man what I mean
like Peter basically treats miles like a
tool to do the less important work of
saving the annoying civilians rather
than treating him like a teammate friend
and an equal almost done here civilians
are all safe how you looking
gunship won't quit I'm right behind you
we'll take it down together no time like
watch how Peter tosses the civilian to
the ground like saving their life was
the biggest inconvenience of all time
because they along with miles's
incompetence let the lizard get away
like Peter Parker would have been able
to continue chasing the lizard if that
guy didn't need help and by the end of
the trailer it seems like Peter's angry
corrupted mind completely views miles as
just another useless living Bee with the
shape of Peter's eyes suddenly changing
to look more like Venoms when he says so
do I very much suggesting that Venom is
slowly starting to take the hell over
but anyways let's talk about Miles
because although there won't be co-op in
this game you will be able to switch
between main characters much like you
could in Grand Theft Auto 5. on top of
the sick new spider Wings mechanic that
will allow our Spider-Man to quickly fly
throughout the city it looks like our
boy miles got himself some new blue ass
electric powers to use in concert with
his yellow bioelectric Venom blast
likely courtesy of his absorbing the
blue energy from Roxanne's new form
reactor at the end of the Miles Morales
game and much like L1 will serve as a
menu for Venom Powers both miles yellow
and blue bioelectric abilities will be
stored in the L1 menu as well with Miles
executing a blue form ground pound
called a thunderburst attack before
taking out this final group of enemies
with his new blue chain lightning
ability which is super handy dandy
especially now that Miles has these cool
new blue electric powers I feel like
Insomniac may have been slightly
inspired by DC's static shock show as
miles and genki's dynamic very much
reminds me of Virgil and his techie best
friend Richie who actually ends up
becoming static sidekick gear but
speaking of denki and his Hunter vulture
robot during miles's stealth sections we
also discovered that the ceilings are no
longer safe for spider people as we can
see miles preemptively taking out a
perched hunter vulture robot waiting for
him before using his new web blind and
web grabber gadgets to get the ultimate
stealth advantage against his enemies I
cannot wait to use all these gadgets
makes me feel like I'm Batman in a
Spider-Man game
but anyways those are the top takeaways
from this new Spider-Man 2 Gameplay
trailer what is your favorite part of
this trailer and what are you most
excited about to experience in
Spider-Man 2 like the story looks like
it's going to be absolutely insane and
do you guys think we could actually see
Raven in the Venom symbiote in this one
let us know in the comment section below
but anyways thank you guys so much for
watching this video you can follow me at
mastertamed on Twitter if you guys want
to see me tweet some weird and
really fun theories but most importantly
you can follow new rockstars wherever we
are on the social medias and do not
forget to hit up nerd riot.chop so that
you can get a cool new shirt for you and
somebody that you love that likes nerd
stuff because we've got a lot of really
great nerd stuff that we're making
constantly for you guys to wear on your
bodies but again thank you guys so much
for watching this video I love you guys
so much and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye
[Music]
thank you
foreign